哈喽大家最近找房班家
有了几个大爷都没有时间好不服了
我觉得我现在的皮膚状态好差
感染这个脸都有点关不动肉了
所以我今晚要做一个交员官服按摩给我的脸
马上碰碰回春子之一下
刚好现在也到年底了
大家又忙
有各种绝会需要参加脸
都没有当起去管理了
这个流程就很适合在现在这个时候
再加就可以给我们的脸
做一个密集修户
今天就带大家来更练一下
坚持定期罪短时间就能感受到的脸
真的会变得又保满又紧脂
好我飞快不能说的马上开始
因为我是有皮所以我会先打开普通道
有皮如果想要好皮膚第一步就需要做好普通
后续的控制品才可以被我们的皮膚吸收进去
不然就被有指全部都堵在外面了
这样我比最上这些
一粒一粒的能够全部都跟他亲酱
我的亲戚方式就是一般我们先服务一个黑头到处业
服务在这种
油脂很厚的区域
先把油脂转化了
一般还会配合一个热盆这样
可以加速毛孔的粘开让里面的脏东西出来
加热盆一起扶10分钟就可以了
10分钟到冻
现在开始尝油脂了
好多好爽
好刚刚翻脸洗完了
我现在感觉毛孔干净了很多很多
洗完脸之后可以把脸擦干
再上一个酸动模
在这种脚脂是比较厚
油脂容易堆滋的地方
带来个2次手统
我用了这个酸动模差不多
我一分钟就洗掉
像我就很好了
好 先去洗脸
洗完脸了
我已经把水分全部都擦干了
现在就到了我们的金碗的金水不分了
开始補焦圆皮拉紧
这一下我们的小脸
但像在秋冬補焦圆的话
我就开始用脸双了
而且我一定会选那种能帮我
促进关键教员身长红
跟远姐就问题的面上
这个资深堂约为教员泡面双
我最近就是非常喜欢用它
前段时间一直在用整个脸都感觉
紧智了很多
真的很牛
它这个的资地非常舒服
就像炒断滑过你皮膚的感觉
涂开之后很快就洗手碗了
你否会有那种喝帮的水滚热门
而且它热而不已有
做装钱就很服务贴
一整天都不会紧供卡分
因为我一般先用一个
精华稍微打的顶
然后就会厚厚的涂上
这个面双了
要涂得稍微的厚一些
因为我们是要配合手法来按摩的
按摩就可以触进我们皮膚洗手碎
也可以放松我们的面部积中
我来分享一下我的手法
首先把手上也弄热一点
用手捏全头然后捏着这个平关键
就这么低着
第三是描中
手朗上推推的碳血
按摩按摩的碳血
我才带在倒
我这下面呢
我才推
我用下来发现这一屏
它的效果之所以会这么好
是因为它里面有植入交缘统的成分
可以从根源非常精准的
给我们皮膚底层
会保交缘
还搭配了非常高效可以帮我们
重新知好基底交缘网的技术
让我们的面部线条变得更加清晰
这两个搭配直接帮我们从底层打到地集
脸才可以是一直碰碰紧紧的状态
完全不松垮
你们看我现在的皮膚状态
真的是挺好的
好现在差不多已经都吸收了很多了
我们再来服务一篇面膜的加鸭
让皮膚更好的把这个练上的营养给飞进去
把交缘谋进去
像我们去美容院的话
它其实也是这个流程来帮我们操作
清潔、舒通、灌服、按摩
最后再来面膜把所有的营养都所在里面
密集的对皮膚吃营养搭餐
多多我服务十分钟
我们现在先开
可以偷轻一点
感觉皮膚吃饱了营养
整个人看起来也禁止了很多
而且感觉是碰碰的有没有
现在用一个这种大师的洗脸经
把脸上的这种多余的精华面双给咱插掉就好了
现在什么后面都没有插皮膚
也是那种亮亮的白白的
看起来还有光索感
再来图一个精华
我的精华也是不交缘的
在图一遍这个面双就可以去睡觉了
这边面双就是宝宝的图一遍就好
不需要像刚才样图那么多了
好了我去睡觉我的晚安
哈喽早上哈喽
当刚起床之后
现在没有洗脸也没有去呼呼
看看现在皮膚状态真的
跟昨晚上是不是两个人
打个皮膚特别特别的洗膚
整个人又嫩有亮的
这个面部线条比昨天清洗铃唱很多
有今天整个人的事晚上走的
初前来也是
挺丘谈谈的